when you're working at home the point is
there is no accountability for me so
when we talk about but when we talk
about these side chicks the first thing
we want to do is look at the woman I've
been that woman that look at a side
chick and be like uh how could you do
that but the realest [ __ ] is how could
you look at your [ __ ] every night and
say how much you love her how could you
post your how could you marry a woman
yeah a child with a woman do all this
and hold your woman up to this high
standard because I'd never see the
funniest thing is this will sit up here
and talk about strippers terrible
prostitutes terrible but fun they're
good girls you just decide you never be
my main as if that's some type of reward
your Mains being cheated on disrespected
degraded and you're putting your main in
danger in the line of be having STDs and
some and being completely and totally
torn and broken apart so there's no
homework or side chick if you both you
both
[Music]
so what'd you guys think about you she
sounds like a side chick that didn't
make it to the main
what do you think should go a point to
be fair thing it depends on the
relationship though like again if like
if it's a secless marriage
difficult to expect the Mantis to stay
in that sad situation but if your
woman's doing everything for you
do you think most men will look for a
side chick if she's doing everything
she's supposed to do
no but
usually those are the guys that just
have a lot of women throwing themselves
at them so it's a lot more difficult to
be biting them away so I might slip
through the correction I mean I mean
should she expect monogamy if she picks
a guy that has women throwing themselves
at them at him all the time should she
expect that
no
no
absolutely I think monogamy is a lie
like if you date an NBA player you're
going to be shocked when you get cheated
on no no
why do women all want that percentage of
God this is what I mean this is what
confuses me because I'm like you know
this is what you're gonna get you know
you're not gonna get that and this is
why I realized what I feel is that most
women in like today
when they get into a quote-unquote
relationship 99 of them are settling
because they're saying to themselves
right I don't think this guy is out here
getting all the girls that's what
they're really saying I think I can pin
this one down and keep him under wraps
because that's what they're really
saying to themselves because the guy
that they know who is getting all the
girls they don't even bother
they don't even bother because they know
they don't look like they've Rihanna's
and the hot city girls and all the girls
that are promoted on Instagram they know
they don't match up to those which is
what the guys at the top are promoting
as the style of women that they want
because if the rich guys started
promoting women that dress like they did
in the 50s with core sets and not
showing no skin
you would see the hot girl summer dry up
as fast as winter because you know what
they want protection provision and peas
they want to get flown up yeah but
there's different type of like if you
looked at politicians wives they're
usually not a really promiscuous and
they don't usually have their ass on
Instagram and that sort of thing it's
just like women look at the NBA players
the rappers the entertainers like the
people that they pick but that's a very
like it like one they're not really good
long-term security bets because a lot of
them go bro like fast money like what do
they say fast money comes with slow
problems so if you get money quick a lot
of times it goes quick too
um and like it's just interesting
because a lot of people will say like
the Kim K's of the world that's such a
small group of society where if you look
at like politicians business owners like
they don't want a girl that has a bunch
of work done and her ass out on
Instagram like I grew up around a lot of
these men that's not who they pick and
that's because they don't but they're
not the ones who are influencing
everybody yeah because you're right
because it's a small again it always
seems to be a small percentage of people
that are controlling the majority I mean
take Melinda Melinda Trump right I mean
I you know I'm not I'm not trying to go
in the Trump conversation but just an
example of a politician's wife she
doesn't ever ask on Instagram like she's
very classy
or even chilled what's his name Joe
Biden's wife Jill Biden I think Emily or
Michelle Obama like none of them and
they also from a different generation
too though I think men want classy yeah
yeah 100 that's what they want they
don't want their their partners are so
on Instagram or boobs out or or anything
like that why would they want that why
do you think so many girls were are
flying to different countries to get
bbls
because it's cheaper yeah
I didn't mean why why not why are they
doing it in the first place oh why are
they doing it
right the competition it's literally a
trend and a track for the attention
fashion thing because you go back
however many years ago you didn't find
girls getting their lips done now all of
a sudden it's fashionable to have bigger
lips same with
um the way like fashion has progressed
throughout the the decades a certain era
it would be fashionable to wear dresses
and skirts and stuff like that now it's
not like that to have your hair a
certain way so I think it's a fashion
thing girls do it to keep up with the
fashion the latest Trend it's a mixture
of fashion and laziness like women that
get bbos because they're too lazy to go
to the gym it's cheating but he's
cheating they want to say no everyone's
she doesn't think you've got to
understand the difference between a
player and she I was having this
conversation earlier a cheetah is a guy
that's going to tell you the only person
you're the only one I'm dealing with is
just you babe that's what she would do a
player would tell you your Monday
and don't call me on Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday Friday Saturday because that's
not your day I think actually what it is
is is because men lie that's what it is
we don't lie we lie because we told to
lie no no no we we we lie and we will we
will make uh women feel like that is
what we want yeah and that's that that
could be the only that is the only
reason yeah but yeah but but it is
literally for for a b that's it
that's the only reason I can think of
okay that that the the masses of women
are going out there doing like trying to
have this same look you see what is this
BBL look because it's a cheat that's
what I'm saying it's cheating it's it's
men
we're telling them those kind of girls
though they get confused with like
sexual attention and like real attention
so they think the victim because guys
sleep with them because they've got a
bbo um they didn't get confused I just
think modern women are lazy because you
can type into Google how to build a
bigger butt at the gym
and it would be pretty easy to come on
it's laziness but they think that that's
what guys want but in reality all they
want is just a bang I mean guys do want
a fat ass that's what I'm saying it's
just like you're doing a real one though
yeah yeah I asked I've asked her I'm
curious fake butt no but a girl with no
butt or a fake butt what would you
picking no but no but no but no but
you're right it depends on what it looks
like because if because some of it some
of his asses are wild that some of these
asses are donkey I don't know like
what's going on but if it's a
a subtle job
subtle job you know slight widening of
the hips like you know you know you know
I realize
then all right cool we could work most
attractive women with bbls are
celebrities is what I realize and then a
lot of people that have that are just
normal people that have done it it just
never looks like a clowns
if you don't have the value that comes
with the stardom and the TV and all of
that and the lifestyle then it doesn't
even work yeah it doesn't fit in a BBL
for boss man at the corner shop like
what doesn't it
like who's really gonna see you when
that you went out that one time because
you got invited by a rapper to come to a
table like unless you're one of the tape
girls or one of the girls that's on the
tables at table set and on the circuit
where they know what they're doing what
are you actually what would you think of
a previous guy bought her the BBL oh
Lord someone else is
back yeah that's you bring those back
man yeah
does this come with warranty no way
okay as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible